I want to talk about one woman who may
be almost indefensible at this stage
which is Gwyneth Paltrow this this case
this is all over three hundred thousand
dollars I'm like what are you doing why
would she let this go to court and not
settle let's have a little look at some
of the highlights or low lights
um may I ask how tall you are I'm just
under five
ten okay I am so jealous I think I'm
shrinking though you and me both I have
to wear four inch heels just to make it
to five five so they're very nice oh
thank you I was yelling at him pretty
loud
that was pretty upset right you're small
But Mighty
actually you're not that small
and you're not trained in accident
reconstruction
me yeah no neither am I you were wearing
goggles a helmet yes okay it kind of
looked like everybody else on the slope
that's always my intention okay probably
had a better ski outfit though I bet I
still have the same one
everyone am I watching this is a court
of law
where's the bucket and my favorite
moment was when she was asked about what
what she'd lost from this terrible
incident she went well half a day skiing
it's like what no I know let's watch
this here we are
and he has deterred you from enjoying
the rest of what was a very expensive
vacation
well I lost
a half a day of skiing
yes okay
what are we watching why is she letting
me I met Gwyneth a couple of times I
actually like her personally but a lot
of people have come out and spoke quite
disparaging about it Dylan Jones our
friend ranji Keith when he did a
nightmare experience with the Toronto
interviewer I interviewed her she was
very very pleasant yeah so
part of us wanted to contest this I
don't get it I just I've thought to
myself why doesn't she just let her
insurance company deal with it she's
insured against lawsuits yes you know
just just let them deal with it back
down why why are you doing it has it
been that
bad of an experience that you feel that
you want to be heard now it's crazy I
just don't understand I mean they're all
Bonkers in there yeah the guy was that
the screeching sound
we're watching something what size shoe
are you taking
who gives up what size shoe you are
Madam who are you anyway you know Owen I
bet you had an expensive skis I mean
what was she doing it's the most bizarre
case anyway I mean there's not gonna be
any winner even if she wins she loses
right and she wants a pound or something
and then cosplay it's all things
Preposterous
um on a more serious and sad Point Paul
O'Grady
um I want to show a little kid he died
at age 67 uh overnight suddenly
um incredibly sad actually he was really
I mean there aren't many people I think
live up to the phrase National Treasure
in Britain but he's probably right up
there let's take a little clip of uh of
Paul
[Applause]
you know what she said when you're on
look at this chance
Foster died on Thursday night he was
little to a cancer he had cancer in his
neck and his face and a tumor in his leg
and the kindest thing for me to do was
to let him go well whatever you're our
boss you're gone but not forgotten kid
give him a big check come on
well and that's now the case for Paul
himself uh he was a great Entertainer
unbelievably funny completely outrageous
a bit like you when you spent time with
Paul O'Grady he would say the most
incredible things but always with a
cackle and a laugh uh warm-hearted
incredibly good broadcaster but had a
unique ability to just make people laugh
both on camera and off and adore him you
could I'd have never met anyone that
doesn't adore didn't adore Paul he's
such a just an unbelievable human being
loved his dogs like you it was a it was
a good man and there's a we've actually
got a lot to be grateful to Paul for or
by default it's a story not many people
know but I finished newspapers rather
suddenly and uh Simon Cowell came up
with this idea for a a talent show and
he wanted to call it got talent and he
went to ITV here in the UK and they came
up with putting it around a vehicle
around Paul O'Grady called it Paul
O'Grady's Got Talent so we all went down
to do a pilot huge success me Simon
Cowell and fern Britain who was then
doing uh this morning
and the contestants were the audience
and it was a great hit and ITV we're
going to launch this in Prime Time
massive thing for Paul massive thing for
me this was my big TV breakthrough and
at the last minute Paul fell out
spectacularly with ITV you and I of
course would never behave like this
never had a massive falling out with
them call them a bunch of petty tyrants
and said I'd rather be sweeping the
streets the work for ITV which brought
an Abrupt 10 to my dream and the show
and then Simon Cowell sold the rights to
America to NBC they repackaged it as
America's Got Talent I went on that you
then joined it after a season number one
show in America and who knows that may
have never happened if Paul hadn't had a
strop with ITV yeah and walked off and
he had a great great career over at um
Americans got talent with the Hof and uh
Harry and various others um so it was a
a great talent and will be greatly
missed I think obviously Irreplaceable
yeah there's nobody that could you know
walk in his shoes he's just an
incredible human being well he's the
kind of guy I always think there's two
types of broadcasting uh especially for
live television they're the type that
when something goes wrong they they're
paralyzed they can't do anything they
just can't move and there are the types
like Paul O'Grady who would Revel in
stuff like falling off his chair or
something going wrong he'd find it
hilarious and he would communicate his
hilarity to the audience who would then
all fall about laughing because and
that's a real talent real that's it
that's the difference between fake and
real well he's authentic and I always
think you and I have had this discussion
before but authenticity is the key I
think on television if people can see
through you eventually if you try and
pretend to be someone you'll not they'll
see through it and Paul was exactly what
you saw on television was what you saw
when you met him exactly all Hearts yeah
great guy uh loved his dogs loved his
fans loved his viewers and he'll be
greatly missed um Sharon lovely to see
you how how he referenced Aussie
everyone references Aussie how is Aussie
he's good he's he's doing so much better
he's
um I think I told you about it the other
night but now it's been announced we can
talk about it he's doing a show October
6 in America he's doing
um
and he's there and it's going to be a
great show Guns and Roses Metallica racy
DC Aussie so the rock is Still rocking
we're going to worry about Aussies no no
he never stopped he'll he's he's back
please send him my best
he wants to talk to you well let's talk
all right I'm available my answering
machine says if that's Aussie I'm here
all right that's right I'd love to talk
to you okay great to see you love you